so wir sind immer noch Live Bilder hier
im Split liebe Zuschauer aus ilpin
Momente wirklich für die Ewigkeit
Immanuel macron Mario Draghi und auch
Olaf Scholz sind vor Ort und auch unsere
Reporter paul ronsheimer ist jetzt
mittlerweile dort angekommen Paul was
kannst du uns berichten was ist dort
momentan los
ja wir sehen hier immer noch macron
durch ihr PIN laufen zusammen mit dem
deutschen Bundeskanzler jetzt
verabschieden sie sich dort ist der
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
der sich gerade hier in erpin die Lage
angeschaut hat wir sehen dann eben Mario
Draghi und
wir sehen hier den Bundeskanzler der
Bundeskanzler
ja wir sehen hier wie Olaf Scholz
durchgepin läuft dieser völlig zerstörte
Ort natürlich mit großer Presse
Bundeskanzler wie fühlt sich das an hier
durch ihr Team zu laufen
keinen Kommentar abgeben auf dem
momentan aber wir sehen das große
Sicherheitsaufgebot und die zerstörten
Straßen in diesem Moment das ist Olaf
Scholz hier in diesem Moment in ihrpin
und da sehen wir die zerstörten Straße
wir sind jetzt wie Olaf Scholz einen
kommentararzt für das in diesem Moment
das ist furchtbar was dieser Krieg am
Zerstörung anrichtet dass ich
umso schlimmer wenn man sieht wie es
furchtbar sinnlos diese Gewalt ist die
wir hier sehen sind unschuldige
Zivilisten betroffen sind Häuser
zerstört worden ist eine ganze Stadt
zerstört worden in der überhaupt keine
militärischen Infrastrukturen war und
das sagt sehr viel aus über die
Brutalität des russischen angriffskriegs
der einfach auf Zerstörung und Eroberung
aus ist und das müssen wir bei all dem
was wir entscheiden mit im Blick haben
es ist ein furchtbarer Krieg und
Russland treibt den mit größter
Brutalität ohne Rücksicht auf
Menschenleben voran und das ist das was
auch zu Ende gehen muss mit all den
Aktivitäten die wir Unternehmen und
unseren Hilfsmöglichkeiten diese
mobilisiert haben aber auch mit den
Sanktionen und alles zusammen soll dazu
beitragen dass die internationale
Solidarität in ukrainischen Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern die Möglichkeiten schaffen
ihr Land wieder aufzubauen die
Zerstörung die wir hier gesehen haben
und die
hier hinter uns auch sichtbar sind sind
ein ganz wichtiges Mahnmal dafür dass
etwas zu tun ist was bedeutet das für
Waffenlieferung Herr Bundeskanzler was
bedeutet das für Waffenlieferung mehr
wählt der Bundeskanzler jetzt in diesem
Moment nicht sagen aber es wird noch
eine Pressekonferenz geben halt weiter
drauf hier
so wir sehen hier in ihr PIN
in diesem Moment der wird jetzt live
wieder in das Auto steigen hat ein
Statement abgegeben zur Situation in den
Pin wie sehr in das bewegt hat in diesem
Moment wir sehen da die zerstörten
Häuser hinter
Olaf Scholz in diesem Moment
und das ist die Situation daneben sein
außenpolitischer Berater
Stefan Plötner
wir sind ein Betroffenen Olaf Scholz in
diesem Moment nach seinem Besuch in
ihren
jetzt hier mit seinem regierungssprecher
Steffen Seibert
Olaf Scholz tief betroffen bei diesem
Besuch
in ihr PIN wir sehen hier die zerstörten
Häuser über den Bundeskanzler dort war
er gerade eben immer noch schwer bewacht
von ukrainischen Militär und natürlich
auch deutschen Sicherheitskräften und
gleich wird es weitergehen
Richtung Präsidentenpalast davon gehen
wir aus dass dieser Termin stattfindet
wir sehen tatsächlich
einsichtlich getroffen im Bundeskanzler
in diesem Moment der diese tiefe
Zerstörung dieser Stadt
diese vor Ort von Kiew gesehen hat
das ist etwas was Menschen sicherlich
verändert wir bleiben einfach noch mal
drauf in diesem Moment wenn das sind
historische Momente der Bundeskanzler
von Deutschland Olaf Scholz in ihre PIN
diesen vor Ort diesen Vorort von Kiew
Bericht von Olaf Scholz schaut Paul dann
sieht man tatsächlich wirklich es ist
ihm Angesicht abzulesen wie sehr Ihnen
diese Atmosphäre diese Bilder diese
Zerstörung aus Botschaft mitnimmt und da
bleibt natürlich schon ja die Hoffnung
bei den Ukrainern dass er eventuell
seine Haltung ein wenig ändern könnte
dadurch dass ihn eben diese Eindrücke
jetzt so mitnehmen
ja ich habe ja gerade eben die Frage
gestellt was das für Waffenlieferungen
bedeutet also was es bedeuten könnte
auch für die deutsche Position hier bei
diesen Waffenlieferungen darauf hat er
keine Antwort mehr gegeben aber wir
gehen davon natürlich aus dass er bei
der Pressekonferenz in Präsidenten
verlassen natürlich danach wieder
gefragt wird was das für
Waffenlieferungen bedeutet
was versprichst du dir denn von diesem
Gespräch mit Präsident silenski was
werden die Hauptthemen sein sicherlich
wird es natürlich um die Eindrücke gehen
die hier in irpin gesammelt wurden aber
auch Themen wie eu-beitrag oder
ähnliches und bleiben noch mal drauf in
diesem Moment wir bleiben noch mal drauf
in diesem Moment der Bundeskanzler wird
jetzt wieder in eines der Fahrzeuge
steigen dass ihnen Richtung Kiew zurück
aus diesem völlig zerstörten vor Ort ihr
PIN bringen wird
wir sehen
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz in diesem
Minuten in ihrer läuft jetzt zurück zu
den Fahrzeugen und er läuft dorthin
zurück um jetzt mit dem Tross zusammen
mit Emanuel macron zusammen mit Mario
Dragon weiter zurück in den
Präsidentenpalast zu kommen aber wir
sehen wie sehr dem Bundeskanzler das
hier mitnimmt in diesem Minuten wie sehr
in dieser
Besuch in ihr PIN getroffen hat in
seinen Augen das ist deutlich zu
erkennen in dieser Situation
Frau vielleicht kannst du uns noch ganz
kurz
Informationen darüber gehen geben wir
jetzt die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen laufen
in solchen Momenten wir sehen wirklich
viele Sicherheitskräfte um Olaf Scholz
herum schwer bewaffnet mit
schusssicheren Westen auch und wir
erinnern uns alle noch an die Bilder von
Annalena baerbock die selbst auch eine
schusssichere Weste trug Olaf Scholz ist
ohne gekommen was bedeutet das warum
trägt er keine schusssichere West
das ist tatsächlich auffällig in diesem
Moment er ist der erste Staatschef oder
die drei Staatschefs die ohne
Schutzweste und vor allem in Anzug und
mit Krawatte hier in diesem Ort sind
vielleicht auch ein Zeichen der
Normalisierung zumindest in diesem
Gebiet aber du hast vollkommen Recht
sowohl Mario Draghi als auch Olaf Scholz
und Emmanuel macron in Anzug gekleidet
keine Schutzweste anders auch als
Annalena baerbock vor ja rund einem
Monat als sie hier war aber die
Situation war dazu diesen Zeitpunkt auch
noch eine andere
der Bundeskanzler noch einmal und sieht
dieses völlig zerstörte aus
thematische Bilder die ihm da gezeigt
werden auf diesen gar nicht so langen
Weg sozusagen durch irpin die Masse an
Zerstörung die man da zu sehen bekommt
ist schon sehr beeindruckend muss man
sagen noch mal zurück zu meiner Frage
von eben Paul also wenn sich diese
Delegation dann gleich mit Präsident
selensky treffen wird was werden da die
wichtigsten Themen sein sicherlich über
die Ukraine auch wahnsinnig wichtig ein
möglicher EU-Beitritt
das sicherlich wir sind jetzt wieder
Bundeskanzler in seinen Wagen geht
nach diesem Besuch das was den Kanzler
sichtlich mitgenommen hat und jetzt in
diesem Moment
geht es weiter
zurück zum nächsten Ort
bleiben noch mal drauf hier in diesem
Moment das ist wir sind in ihrpin live
vom Besuch des Bundeskanzlers im Vorort
von Kiew und in diesem Moment ist er
zurück im Fahrzeug und wird jetzt die
nächste Station gehen das wichtigste für
die Ukraine in diesem Moment natürlich
der Besuch von der Besuch bei Blut und
mir selenski die Pressekonferenz die
dann stattfindet das ist das was wir
entscheidend ist Paul beste danke du
wirst auch das für uns weiter begleiten
und jetzt auch zurück nach Kiel fahren
wir sehen uns hören uns dann gleich
wieder wirklich emotionale Eindrücke die
in die Geschichte eingehen werden
ganz kurz vielleicht noch mal drauf um
mir zu sehen um euch
dieses riesige Aufgebot rund um den
Bundeskanzler wir finden da vielleicht
noch einmal rein das in den Wagen da
sehen wir wie Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
jetzt in diesem Moment
ja Richtung hier zurück fährt wir sehen
ihn durch die Scheibe den deutschen
Bundeskanzler bei seinem Besuch hier in
Kiew in ihr PIN sehr nachdenklich sieht
der Kanzler aus sehr nachdenklich
zusammen mit den
sicherheits-sicherheitsmännern von der
Ukraine von Deutschland vom BKA wird er
jetzt weiterfahren wird er jetzt
zurückfahren Richtung hier jetzt brechen
die Fahrzeuge hier auf die Delegation
macht sich auf den Weg wir sehen diese
Anzahl von Autos diese Sicherheit
gepanzerte Wagen die jetzt weiterfahren
schwer bewaffnete deutsche BKA-Beamte
das ist die deutsche nur die deutsche
Delegation aber natürlich gibt es auch
noch die französische die sich mit auf
den Weg macht das ist ein Berater in dem
Bulli der Regierungssprecher Steffen
Steffen Seibert sage ich schon Nein
Steffen Hebestreit natürlich
zusammen mit seinem Wirtschaftsberater
das ist die Delegation und wir haben den
Bundeskanzler gesehen so live war glaube
ich kein TV-Team aus Deutschland in
diesem Moment in ihr Pin für Sie da
Paul Dankeschön dass du uns diese
Live-Bilder gebracht hast dass du diesen
Besucher für uns weiter begleitest und
wir schalten natürlich sofort wieder in
die Ukraine zu dir sobald es da neues
gibt und natürlich sobald Olaf Scholz
dann auch noch mal vor die Presse treten
wird jetzt machen wir aber erstmal eine
kurze Pause
[Musik]